[Music]
hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and son
snuggling up behind your moon on August
21st 2017 there will be a total eclipse
of the Sun it'll stretch all the way
from the west coast to the east coast of
the United States it'll be the fullest
eclipse the country has experienced in a
hundred years and should get out and
enjoy it but you can't just stare up at
the sky like a monkey from 2001 a Space
Odyssey and expect to return home with
your eyeballs intact that's why today
we're going over some tips to view and
photograph the eclipse and do it safely
first a quick primer a solar eclipse is
where the moon passes between the Earth
and the Sun blocking the sun's light and
casting a shadow onto the earth in the
middle of the day like playing planetary
pool everything has to be lined up just
right that means not everybody on earth
will get to see the Sun completely
blocked out that will only happen for
people in the path of totality which
coincidentally is the name of my
forthcoming solo album the totality
covers a band roughly 70 miles wide from
north to south
it'll first hit the Oregon coast and
drop south as it heads east eventually
finishing in South Carolina if you want
to know where and when you can see it go
to eclipse 2017 nasa.gov if you're in
the path of totality the sky will go
dark and you'll actually be able to see
stars come out now that'll only last for
2 minutes and 40 seconds at best so
let's talk about how to maximize that
time tip number one well the full
blackout will only last a couple minutes
there will be a couple hours with the
moon slowly encroaching on the Sun and
then leaving it afterwards and this is
amazing to see - but here's the thing
it's only safe to look with your bare
eyes when the Sun is a hundred percent
obscured the rest of the time you're
gonna need specialized solar glasses
deal with it warning stacking multiple
pairs of sunglasses will not cut it so
if you're thinking about triple bagging
your face it's time for a new plan
fortunately true solar glasses are not
expensive they come in a bunch of
different varieties you can pick them up
online for just a few bucks however
there's an important caveat there are
several sellers online selling these
things that are not up to safety
standards yes those people will burn in
hell but not before you burn your
retinas nASA has advised that any solar
glasses filters or viewers you use meet
the following criteria
they must have certification information
with this designated ISO number have the
manufacturers name and address printed
somewhere on the product and not be used
if they're older than three years or
have scratched or wrinkled lenses if
you're looking for a reliable company
now
and its partners have verified that
products from these five companies meet
international safety standards only buy
from these guys glasses from those five
companies are already selling out online
but if you go to your local Science
Museum or planetarium they may have some
in their gift shop we've also heard that
some local libraries have them tip
number two NASA has advised that you
don't use any kind of homemade lens as a
solar filter the one exception is you
can use welders glass number fourteen
now it has to be number fourteen at the
very least most welders goggles use
glass number four or five and that's not
nearly enough protection it's got to be
number fourteen tip number three you
know how we said you can't look directly
at the Sun with the naked eye well
multiply that advice times a thousand if
you're using a telescope binoculars or
an SLR camera have you ever seen
somebody fry something using a
magnifying glass in sunlight that's
basically what you'd be doing to your
eyeballs now some companies make
specialized solar filters that you can
screw directly onto your telescopes or
cameras lens
we're talking nd a hundred thousand if
you can find one at your local camera
shop good for you but unfortunately
these are sold out almost everywhere
so here's our DIY solution use some
thick black construction paper and wrap
it around the outer tube of your lens
mark where the ends overlap and tape it
there cut it so it fits the barrel but
doesn't obstruct the focus or aperture
rim apply some thick gel style super
glue to the rim of the cylinder and then
smush it down gently onto a sheet of
solar filter from one of the five
companies we mentioned earlier or onto a
flat piece of number 14 welder's glass
you can cut away the extra film these
filters should cover the whole lens but
not obstruct the shot at all leave it on
until the Sun has completely disappeared
once the last bit of sunlight has
vanished it's safe to remove the filter
for the duration of the totality but
make sure you put it back on before the
Sun starts to creep out again for many
of us this will be a once-in-a-lifetime
event so it makes sense that you'd want
to take a photo of it there are far more
exhaustive tutorials out there but here
are some quick tips if you're using a
DSLR it is not safe to look through the
viewfinder this is because the camera's
lens will amplify the light you can only
use the live view mode on the larger LCD
screen that's why I've chosen to use
Sony's a7 r2 which is a full-frame
mirrorless camera the viewfinder is
actually just a high resolution screen
so I can look through it all I want and
my eyes will be safe it can also shoot
images at a whopping 42 megapixels so
I'll be able to do some cropping and
still make
poster-size photo of the Eclipse a tip
number four because of the Earth's
rotation the Sun will appear to be
moving across the sky it'll travel the
distance of its own diameter roughly
every two minutes if you're using a long
lens that'll make it very difficult to
keep track of one trick to finding it
again is looking at the shadow your
camera makes on the ground adjust it so
that the lens completely disappears from
the shadow and you should be pointed in
the right direction an ideal and much
higher tech solution is using something
like the cube Pro 8200 from IAP Tron
this mount has a database of more than
150,000 celestial objects including the
Sun it can lock onto its position
automatically track it as it moves
across the sky so you never even have to
think about reframing your shot for lens
selection there's a lot of ways you can
go personally I'm going with a 400
millimeter with a 2x teleconverter
giving me an 800 millimeter equivalent
this should give me plenty of detail of
the Sun but still provide lots of the
sun's corona now if you don't have a
long lens don't despair capturing the
setting of where you are in the
foreground is a way to preserve a unique
image of the eclipse and it'll stand out
from all the other close-ups sun porn
out there and lastly some general tips
you're gonna want to find the native ISO
of your camera and use that for most
cameras that's 100 or 200 while the Sun
is still visible and you've got your
solar filter on you're going to want to
use a fast shutter speed if you're in
the path of the totality and it's fully
disappeared you can remove the filter
and you're going to want to start using
a longer exposure but know that there
will be huge variations within the
brightness of the corona so you're going
to want to try a bunch of different
shutter speeds everything from one one
thousandth of a second all the way up to
a full four seconds tip number five
final tip don't get lost in the
technology make sure you're taking the
time to really enjoy this unique
once-in-a-lifetime experience but what
do you think let us know in the comments
below and subscribe to Wired if you
haven't already and with all that being
said there's really only one thing left
to do go see the Eclipse and buy my
debut solo album
[Music]